If you’re like me, you can’t dance.
Actually if you’re like me you’ve been
politely but firmly asked not to dance.
Whatever, I’m just gonna shake, shake, shake,
shake shake, baby, shake it off.
Hello there, dancing machines, Julian here
for DNews.
I’m a firm believer that everyone should
march to the beat of their own drum.
As it turns out though, it may be physically
impossible for some people to keep a beat.
Researchers at McGill university and the University
of montreal recently published a study comparing
2 people with 2 metaphorical left feet to
32 controls.
They had all of them clap out a beat of their
own, then keep pace with a metronome, and
finally clap along with a metronome that changed
tempos randomly.
At first nobody had a problem.
When everyone kept their own beat or followed
a steady metronome, they all had the clap.
This rules out the possibility that there
was something wrong with their motor functions.
But when the 2 tuneless souls had to keep
time with a changing rhythm, they were hopeless.
And I don’t mean they were just clapping
on the one and the three beats like a little
old lady in church, I mean they couldn’t
swap to the new tempo like everyone else could
after just a few beats.
They would try, but be off the new beat by
big gaps.
They were certified beat-deaf.
There’s no explanation yet for why some
people have rhythm and some people don’t,
but the hypothesis is something’s off with
their biological rhythms.
We all have biological rhythms like your heartbeat
and your day/night cycle.
Even the way you talk has a rhythm to it.
but apparently for some people they just aren’t
able to adjust their rhythms based on external
cues.
Before you use it as an excuse to avoid the
dance floor, it’s an extremely rare condition.
One previous study at the International Laboratory
for Brain, Music and Sound Research in Montreal
interviewed dozens of volunteers who claimed
they couldn’t keep a beat and only found
one qualified test subject.
As a sidebar, I think it’s interesting both
these studies were in Montreal.
I don’t like to play to stereotypes, but
we all know French Canadians can’t dance.
Mathieu Dion was the unlucky soul, and at
one point in his life he actually was a Mascot
at an amusement park who had to dance in shows
as part of his job.
Eventually they stuck him in the back so he
could copy his fellow dancers, but it probably
helped that no one could see him.
The study had him dance to a variety of music,
because scientists are cruel.
They found the only genre he could keep up
with was Techno because of it’s loud steady
pulse.
Dion had a good attitude about it, saying,
“I am the first diagnosed in the world of
having no rhythm, which is something great.”
Way to stay upbeat, Mathieu.
Even if you are beat deaf, I still say you
just go for it.
You do you.
Dance like nobody's watching.
Even though everybody is watching.
Shame on them, you have a condition!
Aside from making you feel awesome and chasing
your cares away, Dancing might have some other
cool side effects.
Cristal’s got the deets on the beats here.
Are you afraid of busting a move?
Would finding out you’re beat deaf give
you more confidence or make you find a different
hobby?
Let us know in the comments, and I’ll see
you next time on DNews.